foreign
[Music]
we've also had apologies from councilor
Locke
thank you very much and uh
welcoming it thank you thank you
the item two is the minutes Pages three
to seven confirmation committed to the
meeting held on the 19th of July
I should just do a very good page Turner
Pages three
four
five six
and seven
I'm happy to play some chair there and I
could record meeting they're going to
accept me thank you very much
so all those in favor
and wasn't present extensions
one extension
[Music]
item three is the action Mr com page
eight
so we've just got one action there myth
number 10.
set up lovely meeting between section
151 officer and that's um
do we have any feedback on that how I
want to see a certain volume of what we
have actually met probably more people
mainly because of those accounting
processary here is 21 22 so just
organically
um
okay that's good thank you
I support the agenda Declaration of
interests members with interest should
refer to the agenda items described in
nature of their interest when the items
incident
item five degree agenda items part one
and two and there will be a part two so
we have to vote on the fact we've got a
part to at the moment I'm happy with me
again part two simply goodbye
for a little favor unanimous
item number six is urgent math brought
forward for the position of the chair I
do not have any matters
at this current time so we'll move on to
item number seven
audit reports issued Pages 9 to 13. so I
would hand them to
[Music]
two reports we're presenting today both
both are reasonable so first report on
uh Northern Burrows so uh yes looked at
arrangements to make the area
um including of course the New
Management Center
um so we looked at regions to um manage
the charges parking receipts and
collects the uh charges and so on that
that was all satisfactory
um we noticed that respect review the
parking charges raised which I think is
underway
um it's not been looked at some years
um we did know the need for a health and
safety inspection of the the new center
so I understand that that hopefully
should should be in the health and
safety access to inspection but
um and but overall I think we say well
there's a need to put a new management
plan but the last one which I think was
a draft when I was in 2013 and before
that was sort of 15 years ago before
um previous to that that then came to
capture did one so there's there's need
for a new loan plan uh with this
important giving the increasing number
of visitors and there's considerations
backed biodiversity and climate change
and so on so that that was I suppose the
main recommendation related to Northern
Barrows
um second report on uh council tax again
um a reasonable Insurance again we were
content with the controls in place on
management council tax
um protection rates are comparable to
you know that that um in in recent years
um the one area of concern
um is about protection of um uncollected
council tax
um so um if you if you look at the last
seven years there's about 2.7 million
pounds worth of unaffected tax
um so
um we've said it needs to be
increased emphasis on Syria in terms of
um looking to see whether the debt can
be collected or needs to be written off
and so on
um so one recommendations was perhaps a
dedicated recovery officer to take that
forward and focus on protecting debts
but um this is I suppose a fairly
typical being we've seen across other
councils as you know locked out exist
was on reversely not correcting debt at
certain times during the pandemic and
then secondly happened to manage all the
grants and so on
instead of um collection debt and so on
um the um the report also notes that
we've issued our our final report on
active tires which we've agreed with
management and issue to that effective
torch board so we provide Insurance on
all the risk areas listed here in the
report
um I might add that that we did provide
uh I suppose a lot of recommendations
um and identified some areas of
weaknesses related to them
um and sort of highlighted to measure
the need to track those recommendations
particularly the the high priority ones
such as the it controls they rely
um on that
um on a partner active Leisure so it's
important when you manage that that
partner firstly
um
um and then
um so
um that that's that's my update is a any
questions on on the on the update
recovery of the council tax
um is it is it not possible to get an
outside agency
to do that
yeah just to just to come in I mean
that's not quite as easy as you may
everything
first off they need access to the
council tax system where are we at today
so with this week we started a soft
recovery so essentially reminder lunches
and we booked a December court date
where that's actually
more furniture
and the manager is going to import
business case to actually see getting
additional dedicated with software
recovering of issues on your Hardware is
so there's a lot of work really on
behalf of the county
and the only way to get recovery
16th I just think it actually went from
barking when liability items are issued
because
of people might understand is ugly
billing the foreign
it is
the liability reviews and then they
became a single person and they got
another discount and some move back in
you know so you need that knowledge of
the council tax system to deal with the
inquirers that come in so that's a good
way now I think the only way you have
thought of course range is that could be
the set periods of council tax and if
you didn't know
so yeah I mean it's the case then that
no other local authorities you can have
it outside
of the whole service it's something like
Capital the whole services our thoughts
you know what we have a good day-to-day
collections
uh when we wish it off and struggle
without a staff we did concert
s in the dining area to see if there any
capacity and everybody was basically in
the same goal again
right
next question
um yeah can you take the sort of a base
level let me just simply about charms if
you've said that sort of 1617 was the
base level and you can see the effect of
cobalt
which must must have made death actually
much more difficult
um
but basically what on Earth is gonna
happen in the next year can't can I just
chat oh I understand it in this chart is
that about understanding is that a show
the debt is outstanding from each year
so obviously the 2100 should have my
glasses the 2015-16 is about family from
that year yes so you're not looking over
here that's not what's the death roll
each year you always expected more
recently with the other highest level
they're outstanding
so
um I I can't go into the new clouds yes
and and of course going back to some of
that that would be written off or
something that would have been corrected
so um yeah as you say
um
the chart is basically wrong in two
directions and it's still including
stuff it's written off
no no no I think what we're saying is
that
it's
it's that chart is not said at the end
of 2015-16 there was less um 200 000
pounds outstanding and then out of the
2021-22 yeah there's just 100 million
and that was comparing it too there was
probably a lesser bigger outline in
2015-16 but more substantial than that
it probably would have been 18.
this I think what we're showing is the
department isn't even relating anymore
and they were playing with the
capitalists in any one year compared to
the net the previous year you will
probably expect everything else being
equal in terms of performance it would
be five or six percent higher because it
couldn't be in the legion we all lived
earning which numbers and Council
properties
thank you
um and just with that obviously as we've
said
um you know correction rates continues
to be about 90 70 98 so it's only that
remained two percent which is not
collected which which is reflected in
the these bar charts which is if you add
more that goes towards that 2.7 million
which is over 70 years period
um obviously practically
it's very unlikely there's that debt and
that four five six years will be
recovered I remember the people were
concerned about dealing with the
situation where the main part is as late
as in December because
people saw a problem for themselves
we generally have the main
cause around June early June if one was
always at the market so but prior to
those people dropping for your public
bus Co-op people who will have settled
cleaning funds before
thank you thank you that's the downside
of coming this substitute
similar vein
um I take on board your point David
about the fact that we only retain 12
clinical tax that we collect
but it's still a significant sum if you
look over that seven year period you
know really big sum of money do are we
not responsible for or do we not get
chased by the other recipients of the
country such as Democratic Council Devon
fire and Institute of police Etc
will be that interested in our
[Music]
that's over
probably guessing no it's probably over
40 million pounds for the year yeah so
you know it's a good you know I mean if
you put the amount collectible on that
graph those figures wouldn't look quite
so dramatic it's something we need to do
at night we're announced in that
[Music]
um
Joe Wells Museum
are dedicated Incorporated our recovery
officers yeah and that'll be considered
in senior management team
that will be for some time that we've
got now but the point that I really want
to clarify about it we're not
responsible for
unpaid council tax that we can't collect
not we do so if we have a right so
somebody's astounded uh somebody who
died losing the debt whatever his
circumstances
in prison we have to write on the day we
have that right off whatever that bubble
is we can go to development says about
the county uh 75 so they also write it
off
we do the collectible because we're sort
of writing up on their behav songs
actually it didn't want some point a Big
Bill coming from this you know the
police like fire and rescue saying yours
you know 500 000 unpaid countries
foreign
[Music]
um and also those are confusion because
obviously there's a government nurses
saying don't don't chase get you know
hold up debt and and that even though
that was a resident short period
um officers tended to sort of
happenstance although I know we've got
this message which is not probably
longer than the governor intended to so
so the access and and of course it's
David said you know sort of um a lot of
areas and said in terms of just having
to concentrate on grants
um at the experience of of debt
management so I think it's it's fairly
um you know that's that's particular
I've seen in one of the issues
especially I mean they didn't do most of
the business support now
the business rates
in terms of just this year
that creates a heavy focus on the
council based on your liability
so that came around really before time
for the logistically responding
catch up he was given a job no
noticeable to Consumer like a lot of
opposite reasons
if you're using the council tax and
records as your basis to get the energy
rebound
yeah interesting if I attended to South
handle committee last week and they had
um report on debt but they only gave it
to you dude it was not on that you
really looked at his last two years have
not been typical so actually you need to
look at some four or five years and see
if there's a Trends
um but as I said earlier you know the
actual question that was is continued to
be continues to be good be overall
production rate it's just that
supplement debt management
[Music]
we are going to Department of margin
some people do not very high upcoming
derivation and maybe we might be having
greater issues
and collections that's something that we
have in mind being inside to do but
obviously the fingers are set up for you
know
the power so we are when it's additional
matter
and also
relatively speaking inside that put as a
marketing
relatively speaking in terms of a fairly
stable population
that moves around online the big cities
where you're not students it'll move in
and out to get a new new frequency
foreign
okay
um
so those reports are generally
platform if you wanted Okay so
we
we tend to remember
audit reports and move on to the
internal audit item eight
Pages 14 to 33.
[Music]
of councils and so on
um and then the strategy provides more
detail on how we undertake our work
including requirement to do standard
report and our performance and parts
Insurance majors and so on so
um just presenting our audit Charters
strategy as as we have to do and I would
say any any questions on the net 30
normal detail but that's uh standards
at work
you're provides no I think it's age 30
of the agenda for 18. and that's the
kind of like Department my own quality
assurance
are you actually
managing to do the United States
I know you have pressure in terms of
static movement and people aren't really
want them to do these respect a lot
how you actually
confident that you're going to do that
is
yes it's a standard annual Target and we
typically meet at the most of the class
most years so um even in two years ago
when we had a lot of people working at
homes have managed to meet Tech so so
yeah we are on track we need to meet
loans
foreign
questions
yeah okay well
we received an important and we
noticeable results
thank you very much
the annual report
and I think it's 34 to 66 so at this
time
um so just uh quickly before I go on to
the audience
um
201
and the opinion given back to the last
meeting the opinion hasn't been assigned
yet
um when we issue your opinion he has a
section on that that covers the value
for money world and that's what is set
out in this auditor annual report so
after this meeting
um Julie it was the engagement part of
this sort of signing the audio opinion
for 2021
having presented this or just annual
report
Ed in a position to be able to certify
the audience closed it would have issued
the opinion earlier with about to issue
one opinion and then issue another
opinion would say actually if it's been
given and the audience closed so at the
at the conclusions meeting on the seats
that were updated military
representation 2021 Duty will be on the
side of that opinion
so moving on then so this this so having
said what I just said this thoughts and
report needs to be taken in the context
of
it relates to 2021 by the tribute
so there's there's elements of this and
some of the commentary which has moved
on since and that will be picked up as
part of our 21-22 work of buying the
money which is currently
so so this this report
um it sets out our work assessing the
council's arrangements
for delivering Financial sustainability
governance and and the students so
valuable money your efficiency
Effectiveness in an economy in the
provision of services
um and and really
cutting sort of cut into the sort of the
way this would lead there's there's a
there's three possible outcomes in this
we've moved away from in previous years
where we could potentially qualify any
opinion on valuable to to one where
we've got we can issue
um statutory recommendations which would
be the more significant you know a
significant issue with the council
arrangements and that's where they are
reported publicly and the council has to
respond primitively to that letter the
the next level down is and key what we
call Key recommendations that is if
we've identified a significant weakness
in arrangements and again they are sort
of a higher level recommendation
the the lowest level of recommendations
or the Improvement recommendations which
are just there to to do what they say is
to kind of Aid Improvement try and add
value where we can and to help the
council continually improve improve so
in terms of this report as a whole
we've got none of the statutory
recommendations and none of the key
recommendations we have made a number of
improvement recommendations and when you
know when you read through the report
you'll see that in some of those
management
you know they disagree with the power
Improvement recommendation now that's
not necessarily a problem because
we feel that those recommendations add
value but obviously we accept the fact
that the council's not the finance
amount of resource and then cargo
but you know just looking at everything
they have to privatize where they're
going to spend their time
um in terms of the the report it's set
whilst I'll sort of Take It generally as
read
in terms of each of the
um the key areas so Financial
sustainability you know the review found
that the arrangements are generally
adequate you know this strong history of
Good Financial Good Financial Management
uh we review the assumptions
underpinning the budgets and the
medium-term financial strategy and given
the within the context of the vast
American
sort of
underpins the finance that we found
those to be
um to be reasonable and you know this is
obviously a significant challenge going
forward to kind of setting balanced
budgets and and closing where where
there are gaps
governance wise again
this is 2021 remember so this
effectively covers kind of the coverage
it's kind of occur with years as well so
you know the review found that the the
arrangements
um that adapted adapted well to Germany
well to to governance to ensure that
um decision making continued
um maintaining good Financial control
and and obviously administering the the
grants that have already been spoke
about today
um as well on government risk management
procedures about
um three years wise in terms of
um
Arrangements there you know no
significant issues noted
um Performance Management reporting
arrangements are in place
um yeah we did make one recommendation
this year around
potential use of more benchmarking
but again it you know it's not one where
you know I I do feel benchmarking is
valid but it has to be benchmarking for
a purpose of the key areas and you know
that was the one that out of all that
Improvement recommendations we made
that's the one that I feel would add
have have the most value going forward
but again not doing it just just to take
a box for breakfast or where it's
meaningful
that that was all I was going to say on
the on reports
generally and members have got any
questions
I'd probably play within our section
and where where
your recommendations for improvement are
actually query
they said
why don't we just choose one and then
debate with that one and then um yeah I
just wondered if there was a dialogue
ongoing dialogue or would just be
accepted that you were in person oh no
so we the part process we as part of
closed meeting with you know David and I
will have conversations about you know
where perhaps David disagrees but on
some of those we might think actually
okay we'll take them out but on others
we've kind of left them in there because
what it what this all service and what
these recommendations do that kind of
Aid the process going forward as well
because as things evolved sort of under
the 21 22 22 23 then
you know we can touch base on these
again I said well actually has anything
changed so so they're not going but part
of it is kind of like a bit of record
keeping things kind of show The Mystery
of where we're going
um but but there's none there you know I
you know actually if you don't do this
there's an issue because if that was the
case then there would be more than
Improvement recommendations for us
and you should be
it's one organizing my responses and
whether you think
the third one then
identification and implementation of
further opportunity to support
additional income Generations
are set in a budget and we've got the
member budget working and we're able to
come on
what we're doing
I admitted that time the weird dividend
Quincy to Embassy War we didn't have
another look at working with
and we didn't have a great focus of
maximizing these glasses and charges so
forth it's it's a value
it was a valid observation from Grant
Barton
Pittsburgh a lot of the world moved on
we're now actually doing that so it's
almost like
awesome weekly events
and that comes back to the point I'm
ready to start yeah there's obviously a
timely issue here in terms of
approximity reports even more there's
some kind of moved on and that should
come through in the 21 22 reports
um in terms of that program risk it
tracks through them and then somebody
needs all away and suddenly become
somebody can't become maybe you know a
bit more actually yeah I do feel that we
need to be more Focus here
um
when we've been leaving so far
foreign
[Music]
so
drug problems if you didn't have a
I can even savings through by that
Junction and we did invite very easy to
do that on Advantage but then we could
argue it wasn't the most pressing thing
about Junction but because we are not
the world's moving so fast
the council but that's what we asked
so event was essential
have I answered your question yeah
I thought you would answer very good
okay
on that all the governments and the
third bullet point and proven the
recording and review of the Gibson
Hospitality register
around
medication well six seven years ago I've
never had a gift or anything yeah
oh yeah so it doesn't doesn't account to
the president obligence
I don't think that it's Tom's team that
uh chocolates so it doesn't it
yeah
and again well
I'd probably say eight again at the time
there was no opportunity
you know somebody you know like say a
couple of businesses where we're doing
the Department of Business department
um
but they're not given to any individual
they won't even necessarily know the
individually so I noticed
um the ground about recommendations
didn't really see that it it was a sea
change what we're doing now and and when
he says that you don't want it to be
valued
I don't know but I want to spend the
whole time with Thomas team to get a
bottle of wine it's certain festivals
sorry memory yeah members it's about 15
pounds yeah and I had to take care of a
book in one time thank you
I wonder how many times there's a plan
and I was in a long time ago dance two
live lobsters
foreign
[Music]
um and in terms of the
the overall headline message
um so on page on page 69 we've got the
headlines there which sets out the
subject of biomizing a few of our areas
which is set up on page 71 of the first
tuition we've got qualified opinion
which actually there's no you know their
research experiences about in terms of
our testing and in terms of our testing
there
um
the the areas that are outstanding the
past six hours on page
71. uh that that list there has come
down significantly since we
um
since we've wrote this report
um the key ones outstanding really now
the the receipt of the letter of
assurance of the debit account pension
pension fund origin
um obviously the pension fund
liabilities is a significant value in
the council's balance sheet as part of
our procedures on that we obviously
ground thoughts and actually do the
audience are eventually so they they
large the letter and said it was that
there's no issue with the assets a bit
of help within there and the proportion
that's gone to tolerance District
Council over accurately we haven't
received that later yes orbit we've done
all the rest of our work on the pension
funding and signs of the pension
liability and we haven't identified all
issues today the other the other area
that's outstanding is on the property
plans and Equipment evaluations uh
within that bullet point there mentions
investment property valuation that
element of the work is now complete as
is the work
um set out below it
is in terms of the property plans and
equipment valuations that again it's
another significant estimate and often
experience
just a little bit slow because we you
know we have to
we have to write a value where the value
we have to challenge the assumptions and
then depend all those valuations because
each of those can you know one little
change in in part of the calculation and
organize that valuation because it's
quite a big significant change within
the financial statements so we've got
all the information back from the value
in there and the team we're actually
just working through those final bits
we've got a little bit of work to
complete on the on the academy system
side which covers the housing benefit
council tax and in the oil systems that
that one for me is you know that's just
sort of a process we need to go through
um the two ones I've talked about a bit
more detail there the two that you know
we need to get by analyzed but subject
to completion of those who will be
issuing part of my opinion
um at the head of the 13th of November
deadline and the sign is up which
given the national context of things
in terms of the difficulties that were
facing in terms of delivery we're not
strong thought of really what it burns
and to get that signed off by the end of
November
you know would be would be a significant
achievement
um I I do need to acknowledge sort of
daily and see you know I mean the
audience has been quite prolonged and it
hasn't been a kind of in in and out job
and so you know I'd like to report my
thanks for their sort of patience and
their their sort of the speed it turned
around and dealing with our queries
because that has been
that that's really helped
um
so
value for money work is is still
outstanding and ongoing
um for 2122 that's currently in progress
um page page 86 Etc bindings in our
order plan we we
um we set our potential significant risk
area around the
um
[Music]
we have done sufficient work at the time
of issuing this the two purposes that
you know we we've concluded that we
don't feel like this there is a
significant risk in terms of the
arrangements there but also we we have
to cover up that risk in terms of if
there's any potential impact on the
financial statements as well so we've
done enough work there to make sure that
we're happy that there's no impact on
the financial statements and you know we
don't we don't believe this within the
skin in those arrangements
in terms of key findings from the in the
audit
um
there there aren't any really individual
that I need to bring to your attention
you know in terms of comparing to other
councils
relatively low low level of you know
issues noted you know some minor some
minor amendments made to the drug
financial statements that are pretending
preventing presented towards it but but
again you know nothing looking to
significant so it's really it's a really
clean really clean audit and a good set
of truck financial statements
oh pause there sure if that's okay and
obviously there's any any questions
thank you very much
the first thing I think we need to do
thank you for your work
and David thanks to you and if you can
pass it on to your team don't recognize
that the key thing is
we've had a very stable thing
we've got
really experience lost serving officers
at Southbridge Council and Institute is
often blessed in that certainly has
heard
[Music]
if you can pass that point to that so
definitely impact
[Music]
he was hoping for a smile
thank you
I'm sorry
I can't help
okay
you've got the completion of work on
property plan and Equipment which you
mentioned and investment property
valuations I can understand the uh the
property
valuations you said something
yeah
so the district but what mechanism do
they use for through the plant equipment
by that until you're talking all your ID
equipment all of your Workshop equations
everything you've got yeah policy about
how we depreciate so it basically
and I and I think in terms of that risk
as well the the bigger part of the risk
is on what it should be sort of really
other land buildings yeah so it's not I
mean like sort of equipment and
infrastructure and things like that that
they're valued on different basis
whereas this is more focused on you know
a valuation of a building where you know
the calculation of that might be you
know sort of you know the gross internal
area of the building
and there'll be various like building
indices to get applied to it to come
with a calculation then apply yields or
on whatever base that does various
elements of the calculation now we have
to read before that calculation
and then challenge the value and okay
we've said that this one's got a yield
of five percent this one's got a yield
of 10 why the difference and a lot of
that is because of like you know maybe
the stable Tendencies or what there'll
be explanations behind it but we have to
we have to challenge those and that this
is an area of work that is just evolved
in time and because the the FRC who uh
this is their sort of um
with that kind of main area they're
really sort of focused on they've
redriven the amount of work that we have
to do in this area because it you know
it would really you know we're agreed
every part of the value of this
calculation and agree in that back to to
ensure that that estimate is reasonable
because it's big numbers a small
percentage change can have quite a
significant impact on the overall value
commitment we were talking about the way
it was written down where you said I see
it for three years generally we
I think it's really nice I can't say yes
[Music]
what we say to the Auditors what period
of time I'm going to write down our
assets over so we've made it into some
more right now and see us it's over two
years uh that's a few people I think in
10 years
um I can't think of any other asset
category that we have I was just linking
it to insurance by there is if you're
writing up your it equipment right down
to zero over three years
if something breaks in year two are we
going to get any money back at all you
know just they're two secret things
aren't they really because the insurance
value we're not saying that the asset
doesn't have a value it it's just about
depreciation is all about recognizing
the almost like the use of that asset
over its life right so for for a laptop
for example especially the way
Technologies change rapid moves I mean
say well actually you know somewhere
between three and seven years to
probably you know about the right time
you know in terms of writing that down
so if you pay however much you pay for
it you sort of write it down in that
sort of an equal base you said by the
end of it in terms of recognizing that
expense it's being recognized over the
life of Yasin but the laptop itself is
probably you know it's still properly
functional and still works at the end of
that period so there is a there is a
slight difference in here what we were
for example in one of our workers
and I wouldn't be looking at the
depreciated value of that Refuge Market
won't considering what we get from these
children right
yeah thank you I'm showing that very
much
right no further clients so again we
noticed
you know there's no secret
black hole that I'm not told you about
or liability with a legal action and
that's simply a requirement of the
ground part that we do as well not
intense to go through that any more than
that but itself becomes particular span
at the end of the meeting
thank you
um
item number 12 update on the necessary
appointment process but still in order
to plan but apparently from 20
foreign
we agreed that as the contracts coming
toward its ends that we would renew that
a rank domain would be part of a
national
procurement of external objects
and there's certain things a lot of
challenges based in the audit Market at
the moment
and in section two in the main parts of
Knowles is obviously we've been given
indication of some price if we're going
to expect when the contract remains and
really it's looking like an increase of
7500 pounds on a 50 000 costs that we do
now maybe more
um
in section two it shows the allocation
it will be on it so the public sector
article finding embodied that might have
to expand the number of particles that
are doing local Authority audits
um still remain the biggest player in
the market
subsequent to writing this report and
receive notifications from the public
sector hardly appointed by it that we've
been allocated to Bishop planning of our
Auditors from the 2023 and 24. and that
we should
email notes are accepted and thinking
before the 40th of November who we don't
believe our acceptance they'll assume
our exceptions and there is very limited
ground for appealing against that you
know generally that the ground for being
will be there's a conflict of interest
that you use in Bishop Fleming for some
other piece of work over the next
terminal article McDonald's
so necessarily pay definitely I'm going
to say goodbye to the public sector or
the apartment
as our answered from
2023-24
I mean the same
database of Finance photographic across
and how much is
right well we note that
and you are items number 13 which is the
forward plan
and page 114.
and I definitely we've identified
anything here today that we want to
change support back of course so again
we just you know
I'll do in terms of if you look online
I'll put you down for next turn of all
the department of being able one would
that actually be more likely to be the
trans
uh you know there'll be hey of course
is there anything that um
we've been to an annual football for us
January okay
thank you
okay
right so
now I'm going to move on to 5714
exclusion the public shared movement
the publicly excluded from the remainder
of the meeting because of unlikely
disclosure of exempt information by
virtual paragraph three of part one
paragraph 10 part 2 of chapter 7 of The
Local Government Act
1972. secondly
favor
analysis